boake C podcast special guest in here
representing the Bronx scar liet is in
the building what's popping what's good
it's crazy cuz I I first saw you the
first time I saw you was uh you were
rapping with the with the hot dog
hanging from the string yeah and I was
like yo this sh this [__] is crazy and
then my uh my boy TK who's one of my
Engineers we're riding around
and he was like yo have you heard of
scarlet and I was like nah and then he
uh he played one of your songs and I was
like this [__] is crazy and then he
showed me your instam I was like oh no
I've seen her you know what I'm saying
and so I've been a fan ever since so
it's been dope to see you just kind of
like being extremely original in a era
of unoriginality in my opinion you're
like a one of one right now thank you I
appreciate that yeah how long have you
been rapping I've been rapping since
2016 that's when I like publicly started
rapping but I always did like a lot of
poetry and stuff so I say around like
eight years now I've been rapping so
yeah yeah for you like uh what was the
moment in which you realize like this is
something that's worth like continuing
to pursue like oh I might I might make
it you I mean I might be able to make
some money off this yeah well I knew it
when I dropped Gizzy gobler cuz that's
when I got the most interaction and it
was like everybody like Lil booy shout
out to Lil booy he reposted me and was
like should I sign
and stuff like that and I was just like
oh [__] I could really make it in these
streets with these bosss you feel me
like I'm about to keep going did Lil
booie try to sign you no he just made a
post like okay I don't know you know
he's he signed you know he had the young
blue I mean that didn't work out the
greatest but you know booie is booie
he's a legend yeah like he was like he
shared it it was like should I sign her
you know he's one of the famous people
uh you might have met some famous people
that were you know that you grew up
idolizing mhm I've met a bunch that uh
were not who I thought thought they were
booie is exactly who he is on the
internet like when you meet booie you're
like oh right this is great this is
exactly what who I hoped boozy would be
right yeah he's have you met him yet um
I don't met him yet no I didn't meet him
yet well we just had to do a freestyle
you killed this freestyle over one of
his Beats so ready should go check yeah
that's actually my favorite song of his
so I love that song for sure uh coming
out of the Bronx give me kind of you you
said 50 is your favorite ever your goat
50 is said my favorite rapper DMX my
favorite rapper I love Eminem too like
well shout out to you know it's crazy
cuz I do feel like what is dope about
you is your extremely vulnerable and
when like CU I've watched a lot of your
interviews I watched your Vlad interview
you're very honest about like your life
you've had you know obviously a very
very um interesting come up to say the
least but I think that you have kind of
like that DMX vulnerability about you
that not a lot of artists have these
days cuz I feel like when I was like
listening to DMX as a c felt like I felt
his pain and [__] you know what I'm
saying like is that important for you to
like make sure you kind of like very
very upfront about everything in the
bars and your life and all that yeah I'm
like a open book you feel me I just want
somebody to talk to for real so I just
do it in my music like hoping like
somebody understand me you feel me and I
see like a lot of people relate to me
and understand like growing up people
didn't really relate to me they say oh
she's depressed and stuff like that you
know what I mean but I'm just happy like
to just speak about it cuz they be like
like oh she's depressed she's crazy da d
da no what if I'm just sad you know what
I mean what if I just need somebody to
talk to you feel me like yeah I'm going
through [__] my mom just died obviously
I'm sad you know what I mean so it's
just like putting it in music everybody
relate and everybody can feel it and I
feel like I'm not the only one so it's
like people be like yeah she makes me
feel like I'm not the only one but
really they make me feel like I'm not
the only one you feel what I'm saying